[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning an
urgent but methodical search is underway
right now in the rubble of the partially
collapsed apartment building
near miami at least four people are now
reported dead but authorities fear the
toll could be far
higher they say at least 99 people are
unaccounted for
and of course there are still questions
about what caused the collapse
florida's lieutenant governor jeanette
nunez joins us now with more
lieutenant governor good morning to you
what more can you tell us at this hour
about the rescue efforts
well good morning thank you for the
opportunity to be on your show
as you can imagine urban search and
rescue their teams are working round the
clock
they have been doing that obviously
since early right after
uh the situation occurred we've got the
folks there they're tunneling underneath
they have quite a few individuals all
hands on deck approach
we've got local government state
government federal government everyone's
involved
but it really is tragic when you're on
the scene clearly you're seeing the
pictures but the pictures just don't do
it justice
it is heart-wrenching to see people's
lives on full display
everything from small small personal
items
stuffed animals toys people's
livelihoods
obviously everything on full display it
is just tragic it is governor desantis
last evening declared a state of
emergency we've also heard
president biden say he's ready and
willing to help
has the governor spoken to president
biden
so what we did after the county declared
its local state of emergency which was
the
correct first step the governor declared
a state
a statewide emergency and that has gone
up to the federal government
it is my understanding fema has already
approved the federal declaration
so all of those pieces are in place i
don't know if the governor has spoken to
the president i don't know if the
president has called him
but certainly we have all the pieces in
place as it relates to coordination
and assistance through fema also
important to note that individuals have
been displaced
temporarily those in the standing
portion of the building as well as the
buildings alongside
um it's my understanding that the
buildings next door are now individuals
are allowed to come back in
but certainly the ones that are from
that building they have been displaced
so we're going to be providing obviously
through this declaration
that frees up individual assistance to
allow for
resources and the red cross is also on
scene lieutenant governor uh
as early as the 1990s there apparently
was evidence
that the building was actually sinking a
little bit
it was constructed on wetlands is there
any
recent evidence that the building was
unsafe in any way that we know of
so i don't have that information
currently i know that there are
structural engineers
on site inspectors all of the county
components that monitor
and that are responsible for inspections
are going to continue to investigate to
see
what was the root cause if it was an
issue what needs to be done to mitigate
for other buildings that perhaps may be
in the same situation
but that building was uh built in the
80s obviously before
the county hurricane codes due to
hurricane andrew
the building codes rather due to
hurricane andrew and so obviously
uh you know we want to con we want to
make sure that we get to the bottom of
it so we can provide the families with
answers i think everyone is desperate
for information
they want to have answers as to why this
happened they want to
to make sure that this doesn't happen
again as you can imagine this is
just a terrible tragic scene yeah all
right lieutenant governor jeannette
nunez thank you so much for joining us
this morning we do appreciate it